[Music]
Kim Kardashian is ready to return to
work the mom of two surprised fans by
posting new videos and pictures on her
app and social media accounts on Tuesday
it was the first time she'd posted in
nearly three months since that Paris
robbery and now a source close to the
reality star tells ET shall make her
first public appearance next week at an
event in Dubai quote she's in a very
good place and is ready to move on still
our sources Kim won't be addressing the
robbery publicly anytime soon she's just
not ready yet the source adds that Kim
lost millions of dollars by not working
over the last few months but wouldn't
trade her downtime with her kids for
anything I'm very happy that downtime
included a recent trip to Chicago to
visit Kanye West's mother donda west
spray it was the first time Kim and
Kanye's kids had been there our source
says kanye is doing really good
following his November hospitalization
and will do everything and anything to
make sure he's in tip-top shape for the
family
[Music]
you